thank you all for coming today excited
to talk to you here kind of like right
in the heart of Silicon Valley where so
many amazing things happen and so many
deeply deeply questionable things happen
I want to start out today by talking
about something that might seem rather
small and in fact is rather small in the
scheme of technology and in the scheme
of problems that I think we are facing
because I think it's actually a really
useful example of the way small things
can go wrong so this example is with
Google Maps and a little while back
about a year ago or so Google Maps
launched a new update it was not like
previous Google Maps updates where it
was about sort of improving your ability
to get from point A to point B it was
actually about something different which
was giving you a new piece of data the
piece of data that they wanted to start
giving you was in addition to okay how
long is it gonna take you if you're
gonna take the bus or if you're gonna
walk or if you're gonna drive they also
decided to start telling you if you
chose to walk how many calories you
might burn as opposed to taking some
other form of transit so is this new
piece of data that they start putting
out into Google Maps but they decided
not just to tell you how many calories
you might burn what they also decided
you really needed to know was how many
mini cupcakes that would be so this walk
will burn 1.5 mini cupcakes three mini
cupcakes almost a mini cupcake now I
don't know how many of you are on a mini
cupcake based diet probably not a lot of
you because I feel like that would be a
very short-lived lifestyle because you
would feel pretty awful probably within
a day or two I also don't really know
what a mini cupcake is like how big is a
mini cupcake whose mini cupcake what
purveyor of mini cupcakes that this come
from no idea but what I do know is that
they launched this to several hundred
thousand iPhone users to start out and
almost immediately after they launched
this update they started getting some
feedback one of the ones that I really
loved came around 8 o'clock p.m. the
night that she got it this journalist
Taylor Lawrence Taylor Lawrence writes
about technology a lot her work is great
but she started tweeting about it and I
just want to walk you through what she
went through as she started playing with
this feature
around 8 o'clock p.m. she notes that
it's happening and the first thing she
notices is oh wow here's a new thing
that exists and pretty soon after that
she's like huh I didn't actually opt
into this and you can't opt out of it
and then she starts walking through all
of her feelings about it immediately
this is just her encountering this
product feature the first time right
so one thing she's like this is really
triggering if you've had an eating
disorder she's next no it just generally
feels shaming she talks about how like
nutritionists don't all agree about
calorie counting in the first place she
talks about some of the difficulties and
understanding sort of what we mean by
calories she talks about like why
mini-cupcakes on and on and on up until
about nine o'clock that night so between
eight and nine o'clock p.m. she covers
all of these different reasons that this
particular product feature might be bad
right she talks about the fact that
nobody opted in couldn't opt out eating
disorders general Shea meanness calories
um
why why cupcakes who needs cupcake data
in their life I don't know one of the
things that came up and it wasn't worded
exactly this way my interpretation is
that like a pink cupcake is not really a
neutral food like a pink cupcake is sort
of encoded with a lot of cultural
meaning which is to say cupcakes are
very American cupcakes are also very
kind of white and middle-class and a
pink cupcake is very feminized and all
of those things are kind of important
when you think about this being
something you're gonna roll out to sort
of the world and then finally the last
note you have is that a perpetuates diet
culture now you can look at these
examples and you could say I disagree
with that you could look at this and you
could say actually I think that feature
would be fun and helpful for me I don't
mind the cupcake at all and that's fine
you could have all of those opinions but
the fact is in the course of one hour
she came up with a lot of different
reasons and a lot of different people
for whom this feature was actually a big
problem right over the course of one
hour she came up with all of these flaws
with this particular feature within
three hours Google took a feature down
so great they took the feature down it
seemed ill-conceived but I look at that
and I think
but how long did they spend on this
right how much time did it take them to
build this particular feature how many
meetings did they have how many people
were involved who are all the bodies
this had to go through for it to
actually get launched now Google has a
lot of money and maybe we don't care
about them wasting some of that money on
ill-conceived features however at no
point along the way that anybody say hey
what if this is a bad idea or even if
they did they weren't listening - I've
been in a lot of meetings and a lot of
tech companies and I can tell you I bet
they spent more time debating like what
color the frosting should be on the
cupcake or comparing illustration
options from multiple illustrators than
they did asking the question who does
this fail for and I think about this
example all the time I think about all
the time because I think it's a perfect
encapsulation of like the way that we
often in technology gets so narrowly
focused on this one version of things
that we think is going to be great and
we don't really think about the impact
of what we're making on the people
around us on the communities that we're
dealing with and on society at large and
there's all these small choices and I
think that the small choices are
actually really important the small
choices that you might end up making if
you're working in industry and you're
out there you know working with a design
team or UX team or a technical team and
you're making these little choices
day-to-day about how a product works
that can actually add up to huge
oversights so for example my friend Dan
Hahn got this email from his scale and I
love this email very much he has a smart
scale so he gets email from the scale of
course right here we are and he gets his
email from a scale that you may notice
here is made out not to Dan but to
somebody named Calvin your hard work
will pay off Calvin don't be discouraged
by last week's results we believe in you
let's set a weight goal to help you shed
those extra pounds you may also notice
that the average weight of Calvin is
twenty nine point two pounds because
Calvin is a toddler and it's super weird
but every week he weighs more and
scale is very confused by that because
obviously gaining weight is bad so the
scale is gonna give you this handy
reminder to just drop some of those
pounds because the people who decided
these product features they didn't think
about anything else besides weight loss
as being positive and maintaining a
weight as being positive and the idea
that somebody would gain weight week
after week could only be a problem and
then there's a flipside of that too
which is the same product this is a push
notification actually that Dan's wife
received that was congratulating her
congratulations you've hit a new low
weight now she did not sign up on a
weight loss plan with the scale it
wasn't like she told the scale that like
she was trying to lose weight all she
did was use the product set up sign up
for the app and she started getting
these push notifications for this
particular push notification she had
just waited herself after giving birth
and it was in fact a new low weight but
it wasn't a new low weight for any sort
of congratulatory reason exactly and it
was kind of funny that she got this
right after her giving birth but there's
so many people that this is actually not
at all funny for right this is actually
very problematic if you're somebody who
has an eating disorder like we talked
about before but also people who let's
say have a chronic condition I know
people with chronic illnesses where they
have to really monitor all of these
different signals and science in their
life that whether something's going
wrong or not and for them some people
like losing weight is actually a signal
they're getting sick it's a small thing
in some ways to get this sort of
congratulatory message but it speaks to
that kind of narrow focus and the way
that we're not really thinking about the
range of people that use our products
and they can come down to just like a
tiny little bit of copy that reveals the
biases reveals the way that we're
excluding people in the things that we
make and reveals just how little the
people who are designing technology are
thinking about people this is from a
period tracking app it is called cycles
and many period tracking apps have this
feature or a similar feature where you
can share your data with a partner I
love talking about period tracking apps
because I think people are uncomfortable
when you talk about menstruation and you
shouldn't be and I also love talking
about period tracking apps because so
much weird gender bias and like weird
sort of
ideas about people get embedded in them
so there's a rich ground but in this
particular period tracking app the way
that they have talked about their
feature to share your information with a
partner is super heteronormative and for
no reason right like it's just copy it
says just between you and him keep him
in the loop there's literally no reason
it needs to do this there is nothing
about the feature that works better if
your partner is male it's like you're
adding an email address right but nobody
thought about it and nobody flagged it
and you can take a product like this and
bring it to market without anybody
saying like hmm what if the user has a
partner that's not a man and if that's
not coming up where are all the other
places they've made assumptions about
who is using this product and why
they're using this product right if
nobody is noticing something that's so
close to the surface like this this
thing that you could change in literally
four seconds of copywriting what else
aren't they noticing and so I think
about these small things so much and one
of my favorites is this one from from
tumblr it's a little bit because I love
it so much so tumblr send out a push
notification - she's an Irish novelist
actually her novels are awesome they're
available in the US now but at the time
that she got this she was like a to be
published author and so like a lot of
authors were trying to get published she
was on Twitter a lot she tweeted out
this screenshot that she got from tumblr
beep beep neo-nazis is here and it went
viral and I talked to her about it and
she said that when she tweeted this out
she was actually really freaked out
because she was like oh no have I
accidentally followed neo-nazi tags on
tumblr like am I am i a neo-nazi fan and
tumblers system like what is happening
here why am I getting this and she
couldn't figure out why she was going
through her settings she couldn't find
any reasons that she would be getting
the latest neo-nazi content sent to her
phone and what she finally found out
when she talked to people at tumblr was
that it was because she'd read a couple
of posts about the rise of Mia fascism
in the United States and so tumblr
decided that obviously she wanted to
have push notifications of all the
freshest neo-nazi content now
that's one side of it the other thing
that's happening here is of course the
notification she got beep beep neo-nazis
is here which totally doesn't really
work very well and then in fact somebody
else started sharing I get other
screenshots they got for the same
notification but with different content
so there was one guy who shared
beatbeat mental illness is here and he
was like well they're not wrong but I
don't really feel great about this um of
course you know nobody sat down and
wrote beep beep neo-nazis what they did
is of course they wrote a text string
right so somebody wrote a text string
it's like beep beep trending topic is
here and then that texturing goes into
their system and that could get pulled
out for different circumstances
different reasons right this texture
just doesn't actually work well for a
lot of different topics people might be
talking about on tumblr it kind of only
works if you're talking about something
fun and tumblr being fun might have been
sort of one of the original purposes for
it but certainly there's a million
people using tumblr for all kinds of
reasons to talk about all kinds of
issues including neo-nazis and mental
illness and a million other things but
the real reason I wanted to bring this
up is that I was fascinated by the
conversation that happened afterwards so
on Twitter the lead writer at tumblr at
the time not sure if he's still there
tag savage he said just kind of
off-the-cuff he said something that was
really revealing to me and that I think
sucked like summarizes so much of what
the problem is we talked about getting
rid of it that notification but it
performs kind of great that mentality we
could not do this but you know what it
performs I think that that is what's
underlying so many of the really huge
consequences that we are seeing emerging
constantly in tech so many of them that
like I'm not even gonna be able to
mention some of the most recent ones
because it's like every day I got to be
up on the news but for example how many
of you saw this story from about a year
ago when James bridle first started
talking about this it's YouTube's creepy
kid video problem so what was happening
was YouTube had thousands and thousands
and thousands and thousands of videos of
creepy and weird violent content that
was being marketed at kids and showing
up in their kids app this is one
screenshot this is a knockoff Peppa Pig
video so in the traditional Peppa Pig
cartoon I don't know how many of you
watch Peppa Pig I do not but the way I
understand it traditional one Peppa Pig
is scared of the dentist goes to the
dentist that's how kids TV works in this
version Peppa Pig is scared of the
dentist goes to the dentist and then it
morphs into a violent graphic torture
scene so there were thousands upon
thousands of videos like this not just
Peppa Pig not just cartoons also live
action with all kinds of super creepy
violent sexualized and just plain weird
content and they were being uploaded and
tagged with kind of what keyword salads
what James bridle called them and then
because they would have all these
keywords in them that were keywords that
kids liked like keywords that related to
things that they knew kids already liked
and they'd be tagged with things like
the brand names for the cartoons kids
were looking for the auto plate and
promoted to kids so you start out you
know if you maybe hand an iPad to a kid
in a restaurant or they're watching
something in the back of a car at a long
drive or I'm not a parent but from what
I understand you just need 30 quiet
minutes you hand the kid iPad and
they're starting out by watching
something on the traditional Channel and
it's a regular Peppa Pig video and you
think fine and then suddenly without
even realizing it they're immersed in a
deeper weirder darker web and you don't
even know what's happening and the thing
is this content performed this content
got a lot of views that was good for
YouTube there's a lot of content like
that that has been good for YouTube I
don't know how many of you have been
paying attention to some of the stories
coming out recently about the way that
YouTube has sort of sends people toward
more and more extreme content I find
this one very funny where it's just sort
of like yes I just want to watch these
videos in order they're labeled one
through fifty let me watch them in order
and YouTube is like maybe you want to
watch number seven the number 14 and the
neo-nazis
and that's actually a lot of what
happens on YouTube so this is very this
is a funny tweet went around the
internet but then turns out that that
was a really really common way that
YouTube is working so Zeynep did Becky
start to talk about this last year she
said you know during the 2016 election
she made a point of watching youtube
videos of Donald Trump rallies because
she was trying to you know see what was
actually happening at these rallies
she's writing an article about it soon I
noticed something peculiar peculiar
excuse me YouTube started to recommend
the autoplay videos for me that featured
white supremacist rants Holocaust
denials and other disturbing content
okay so it immediately went from oh
you're interested in Donald Trump you
have to watch this Holocaust denial
video next obviously that's what you
want but it wasn't just that so she got
interested in that and she said okay I'm
gonna create a new fresh YouTube account
and I don't know sure how many of you
are familiar with the Zeynep defect
she's a digital sociologist and she's a
professor and she went through this with
sort of research rigor and she said okay
create this new account I'm gonna see
what happens
started watching Hillary and Bernie
videos lo and behold very very quickly
the YouTube algorithm started showing
her videos of conspiracy theories things
like the existence of secret government
agencies allegations that the US
government was behind the attacks of
September 11th almost immediately right
just sending her down this more extreme
path she found that it was happening
over and over no matter what she watched
it wasn't just watching political stuff
she watches something but vegetarianism
and they're recommending a video about
veganism you start watching something
about jogging and there's suddenly
you're watching something about ultra
marathons you're never hardcore enough
for YouTube's recommendation algorithm
it's always sending you to content that
is more and more extreme upping the ante
and maybe that's not a super big problem
if you're talking about things like
running videos but it starts to get it
to be a big problem we're talking about
things like extremism you know a friend
of mine actually recently told me that
this was happening to her own mom where
her mom is Jewish and was watching some
YouTube videos about Israel and then
suddenly she was watching some extremely
conservative videos about Israel and
then suddenly she was watching stuff
that was just blatantly anti-arab and
she hadn't quite realized what was
happening she thought she was learning
about her faith and she was getting
sucked deep
and deeper into this web and the thing
is this contact performs kind of great
you can make a lot of money promoting
extreme content to people so recently
just this month there was a story that
came out out of YouTube about how long
employees have been raising their hands
and saying that this is a problem and so
one employee said that they wanted to
flag troubling videos that weren't quite
hate speech but that were like close to
it and stopped recommending them right
so if something is sort of near the cusp
of being considered hate speech maybe we
shouldn't be pushing that in people's
faces somebody else wanted to track
videos in a spreadsheet to try to chart
some of the popularity of extremist
content and sort of like keep tabs on it
and see what was happening over time
somebody else was really getting scared
of the alt-right video bloggers they
wanted to create a vertical to show that
how popular those people were every time
they got the same response don't rock
the boat that's a big problem at YouTube
that's been a big problem at YouTube for
a while but it's not a big problem only
at YouTube it is a big problem
throughout this industry that we are
bright smack in the heart of for example
I want to talk a little bit about a very
different story with some of the same
underlying problems and it takes us into
Germany
so Altena Germany is a small town see
right there kind of near Cologne and
Dusseldorf and in all Tana Germany this
is a tilman took in a lot of refugees
and it had a really positive feeling
about refugees so they were allowing all
these refugees in and there was all of
these events to welcome the refugees
into the community there was all kinds
of campaigns to donate things to the
refugee families coming in there's
generally positive sentiment about
refugees being part of their community
but then in 2015 a young firefighter
trainee named Dirk Deng cows went and
tried to light this house on fire which
was a refugee group home now
dirk dunk house had no history of
extremism he had no history of violence
nobody thought that this was something
that he would do he wasn't even
particularly political there was only
one thing that he'd been doing just one
thing he'd been doing
that they could point to that had led
him down this path he'd been using
Facebook and he'd been using it a lot
and in fact this community all Tayna as
a whole was using Facebook a lot higher
than the national average usage and in
Altena Germany and then a lot of other
places in Germany some researchers
started looking at all of these
different hate crimes all of these
different attacks on refugees and what
they found when they looked at 3335
anti-refugee attacks in Germany all of
the attacks over a two year period what
they found was that there is one thing
that correlated all of them and it
wasn't how much income the community had
it wasn't whether the community had a
high level of education or a lower level
of education it wasn't whether the
community was historically more
left-wing or right-wing had nothing to
do with things like how many newspapers
were sold in the community or whether
there was a history of hate crime of the
community prior to the refugees coming
in the one thing that tied everything
together the one thing that was
consistent across the board was higher
than average Facebook usage anywhere
where Facebook use was higher than
average they experienced more attacks on
refugees it was true in virtually any
community big city or small town
affluent are struggling liberal haven or
far-right stronghold anytime per person
Facebook usage was one standard
deviation above the national average
attacks on refugees increased 50 percent
reliably over and over and so what they
started finding in this study was that
the algorithm was built around that one
core mission in a kind of the same core
mission of YouTube right maximizing user
engagement and anything that tapped into
negative primal emotions like anger or
fear performed best they perform kind of
great and so anti-refugee sentiment was
really common on Facebook even in a town
like Altena that actually in real life
had a pro refugee sentiment the thing
you would see on Facebook was as if all
of your neighbors agreed that the
refugees were bad even when that wasn't
true and so what you have over and over
and over again is a system that's
prioritizing right these extreme views
all for the sake of what connecting Pete
this is from a memo that Andrew Bosworth
boz at Facebook wrote in 2016 but was
just leaked last year and it was about
ugly truths and he said that the ugly
truth is we believe connecting people so
deeply that anything that allows us to
connect more people more often is de
facto good all the work we do in growth
is justified all the questionable
contact importing practices all the
subtle language that helps you stay
searchable by friends all of it and as
I'm sure you know things like subtle
language that helps you stay searchable
by friends that's like privacy settings
you cannot understand that encourage you
to be as open as possible the work we do
in growth all the work we do to reach
more people more often anything that
allows us to connect people is de facto
good so by that logic content that
promotes refugee attacks is de facto
good because it's popular right if that
is how you look at it if you are to the
point where anything that connects more
people more often is de facto good then
you can justify anything and of course
they have these books historically made
quite a lot of money look they made
fifty five billion dollars last year
they may even be on track to exceed that
this year although I hear they might be
fined five billion dollars so we'll see
for their privacy violations over
Cambridge analytical we'll see if they
can still net higher than fifty five
billion but then fifty five billion
dollars in ad revenue last year right
they only had forty billion in 2017 so
in the year that Cambridge analytical
happened in in the year that we started
seeing an endless amount of negative
press coming out about Facebook they
still made a record amount of money so
what we're really getting at is a system
in technology where so many of the
companies that I think we've spent a lot
of years idolizing or looking to as
being sort of leaders they're not just
vulnerable to being abused they're
actually literally optimized for it
because the exact thing that makes them
money is the thing that is causing
problems in society right they're
optimized around abuse and the thing is
it's not just about sort of big tech
social media there are so many
challenges that we are facing across
technology across any technology
adjacent industry when it comes down to
all of the decisions that we're now
looking to technology to help us make
and all the ways that we're embedding
technology into all kinds of thing
they might have bias that we are also
embedding along with that technology so
let's talk a little bit about that
problem - there's so many issues coming
up constantly about algorithmic bias
endless examples and I mean it's going
to talk about a couple that I think
really helped to sort of start thinking
and driving the point home one of them
is a system called word Tyvek where
difficult years ago and what word Tyvek
does it's taking words and finding
vectors so it is helping with natural
language processing by finding
relationships between words right and
the idea is that that can help you with
some like higher ordered thinking so
what they did is they took this is
researchers at Google they took Google
News articles and they found three
million words from those Google News
articles and they said okay what are the
relationships between these three
million words and what can that tell us
about how language works and what things
mean and so it could start doing some
stuff that was pretty cool and was
pretty helpful like it could fill out an
analogy for you and that's useful when
you're thinking about the way that
natural language processing needs to
sort of be able to mimic sort of our
human understanding of things analogies
are really helpful for that so Paris is
- France as Tokyo is - Japan awesome
great right however it could also fill
out other kinds of analogies that are
maybe not quite as awesome like man is -
computer programmer as woman it's a
homemaker now that is not true in the
same way that Paris is - Frances Tokyo
is - Japan but forward - Beck that was
literally true it was just this true
because in the data that it had learned
from three million Google news articles
right from that data that was true the
relationship between man and computer
programmer was similar to the
relationship to in woman and homemaker
and when you pause and think about that
you're like okay well you can actually
see why that might happen right you
think about Google news articles well
Google News articles are written by
journalists so they're written by people
people have biases okay that's one also
people have jobs and there's probably a
lot more women who are quoted in Google
News articles who had their job listed
with them
who were homemakers then there were men
right there probably very few men who
said that their job or their title or
they weren't referenced as a homemaker
that would be unlikely okay and then you
just think about all of the different
ways that that language plays out over
time and then you also have to think
about things like well who did
journalists cite in their work do they
tend to cite more men than women yes
that's actually true it's oftentimes you
will find that the number of men cited
in a piece where they're looking at an
expert perspective is like multiple
times under of women and so the data
doesn't necessarily reflect truth it
doesn't even necessarily reflect reality
what a reflects is a body of information
right and that body of information is
only what that body of information is so
the algorithm wasn't wrong it was just
only trained off of a very very limited
amount of info but what's happening and
what you see constantly is you see
companies all kinds of companies that
are snapping up natural language
processing packages and using them right
you just pull them into whatever other
thing you're building and you don't
simply think about who built it and how
they built in and whether it's good or
bad you're not necessarily thinking
about whether this is something that's
going to perpetuate biases you're just
thinking that you need to do natural
language processing cuz you're building
a chatbot and here's a package of
natural language processing that I can
just buy and plug in and so we start to
think about the way that we end up with
these and by these biases really
embedded deeply in places and with
people who don't necessarily think about
that and don't know about it and aren't
there 2d bias these results in fact I
don't know how many of you saw the story
come out a couple months ago where
Amazon was like yeah we tried to create
a hiring tool using AI and it wouldn't
stop discriminating against women this
one was interesting because they've
worked on it for like two years and they
had to throw the whole thing away two
years because their premise was that
they wanted to find and recruit ideal
candidates right Amazon has grown very
rapidly we could talk about the Amazon
business model another day but Amazon's
grow very rapidly they wanted to find a
recruit ideal candidates maybe some
people like you all here and so what
they did is they said okay well what is
an ideal candidate well an ideal
candidate must be similar to all of the
successful and
that we've had over the years so they
took ten years of data about the people
they'd actually hired right so 10 years
of resumes that they received and pulled
the ones that were people that they
actually hired in the company they said
yes this is what good looks like get us
more people like this what they found
was that actually this revealed a lot
more about their hiring practices than
it did about actually getting good
people in the door because they found
that it immediately downgraded any
resume that used the word woman so let's
say you went to a women's college or
maybe you were on like a women's
lacrosse team maybe you were in a
women's leadership group you would lose
points immediately
interestingly it didn't care whether you
knew desired coding languages so if the
job listing required you to know Python
it did not care if your resume said
Python because in Amazon's actual hiring
history that was not a factor that
actually mattered about who got hired
however it did really care what kind of
language you use then if you use terms
like executed and captured more
aggressive terminology it would give you
extra points as being a better candidate
turns out that it was almost entirely
men who happened to use that language so
lo and behold all of the best candidates
still are men again they spent two years
on this and they had to throw the whole
thing away because they couldn't figure
out how to deep bias these results
because the entire premise right we're
gonna hire people like we've hired in
the past turned out to be a problem it
turned out that the bias existed before
you even got to building any of the
technology or how many of you have heard
about predictive as predictive came out
a couple months ago pretty comes a fun
one where if you are a parent and you
want to hire somebody to take care of
your children so a nanny or a babysitter
you want to have somebody you can trust
of course right and so predict them says
well we're gonna help you see who's
trustworthy by having you run people who
might be taking care of your children
through this screening process well we
are going to look at their social media
we're going to figure
are they trustworthy or not the way that
they did this as they said okay you want
to find people you can trust well let's
figure out what a good babysitter looks
like so who did they ask they asked what
they called mommy bloggers so they were
basically like let's go talk to moms who
run blogs and ask them what they look
for in a babysitter that may or may not
be representative of what parents in
general want I would argue it's probably
very much not representative of parents
in general but that's who they ask that
was the criteria that they got then what
they did is they trained an algorithm to
assess prospect social media posts
against those standards so they said
okay this is an ideal babysitter now
let's compare what you post online to
that ideal babysitter
I would always I would never be hired as
babysitter if this was the criteria okay
but that's this we're gonna use right
we're gonna use what you post online to
decide are you a good babysitter or not
now a neural net would then go in and
classify what you said on social media
as abusive or polite positive or
negative and then they had a second
model that would decide your risk level
how risky of a babysitter are you based
off of that one of the interesting
things about this particular piece of
software is that the AI was trained to
go out and try to find instances of you
out there that you had tried to keep
private so for example let's say you had
social media accounts that were not only
not using your real name and not using a
photo of yourself but there were also
not tied to an email address that was
the email address that you were using on
your resume that you had tried to keep
private and separate from your
professional profile it was still trying
to go out and find those right so it's
gonna find your secret Twitter and it's
gonna take a look at how risky you are
so there's a journalist Brian merchant
toukas moto he wrote about putting
people he knows through the process and
the first person he put through was
Keanu Keanu is his actual babysitter
this is the person he entrusts with the
care of his children and when he started
putting her through the process um he
started noticing very quickly that she
was considered low risk but not the
lowest risk and that actually down there
it's a little hard to read in yellow but
she was listed as a moderate risk for
disrespectful attitude now
you may notice that Keanu is a black
woman you may know there's a history of
calling black women disrespectful and so
he started wondering why did I think
Kiana is disrespectful exactly why is
she a moderate risk here and so he
started looking at okay well what are
the social media posts that it found
that it decided were problematic didn't
put on any makeup but I got that post
poop glow it's one of them which I'm
sorry I just think it's funny she said
their legal system is an effing crazy
map she hasn't decided she's an indigo
child or a narcissist and 2018 is the
year that she stops talking those
are the posts that it decided were too
disrespectful for her to be a good
babysitter no you could say that like oh
yeah that's a little disrespectful or
like I see why that would be flat or
maybe you're fine with that but what I
think is really interesting is the
second person he ran through the system
which is a friend of his who is a
stand-up comic you might see where this
is going
okay friend Nick is a stand-up comic you
will notice that that he was labeled as
low risk
very low risk no flags whatsoever and
unlike Kiana who had that yellow bar
that was like moderate risk
disrespectful attitude nothing for him
so what are the kinds of things that he
tweets about well you're just a few
choice samples from his profile he talks
about Tom Brady and the vice-president
involved in a sexual act he refers to
the president by various various unkind
descriptors he is in general I would say
I would argue demonstrable less
respectful because of one key difference
nothing in Kiana's profile was directed
at anybody else right there was nobody
as she was saying anything - this is all
directed at specific human people now as
you probably guess I have not great
opinions about the current president but
that aside that's still a person and
you're still directing hate at a
specific person right um this was
labeled as zero right see
totally neutral totally fine totally
fine so Brian Merchant went and talked
to the people behind predict him and
he's like what gives and they were
immediately like we're not racist or not
racist we're definitely not racist
we are definitely not racist because
they said you know what there's no way
we could be racist we can't be racist
because you see we don't look at
ethnicity or skin color
they're not even things in the algorithm
there's no way for us to enter that data
but it isn't about whether there's a
field that says like is this person
black check here that's not what it's
about it's about inferences right it's
about all of these different tiny little
pieces of data that this algorithm is
using in ways that actually he probably
does not understand because it's doing
all kinds of work behind the scenes and
making more and more and more
assumptions as it goes so the algorithm
is what it's picking up on sentiment
sentiment deemed to be problematic by
some group of people so the question is
who's sentiment is it picking up on who
are the people that think that this is
problematic well that depends on what
the training data was right so was the
training data that it learned from what
were the norms of that training data and
then whose definition of aggressive are
we talking about whose definition of
angry who in our society gets labeled as
aggressive and angry all the time
turns out black women now I don't
actually know what's happening in this
algorithm and in fact I don't he does
either
but the real the real problem here is we
can't look underneath the hood because
there is no transparency because they
don't share any of the information about
how this thing makes decisions because
all of that of course is proprietary so
just the other day of a report came out
from the AI now Institute if you're
interested in this stuff I strongly
recommend reading it it's called gender
race and power and AI and they talk
about how large-scale AI systems are
almost exclusively developed places like
this right elite university laboratories
hmm wonder what they might mean by that
and then space is in the West that are
extremely white a
fluent technically oriented and male
whom wonder where that is we are in the
middle of a place that is designing a
lot of Technology from a very limited
point of view and that in that
particular dynamic you have a tremendous
diversity problem that is making its way
into all the artificial intelligence
that we are building and all kinds of
billions of different applications right
and one thing that they noted in this
that I really want to point out is that
it's not just about women because so
often when I talk to people in tech
there's a conversation that then goes to
like Women in Technology which is a huge
issue for sure
but you know I'm a white woman working
in technology and one of the things that
I know is that also also that leaves out
a huge number of people right we're
talking about gender but we're also
about race and we're fundamentally
talking about power it affects how a I
companies work what products get built
who they're designed to serve and who
benefits from the development and if
we're not taking all of that into
account in the things that we're making
and the things that we're researching
even here at Stanford then we're not
going to be able to build things that I
think we can be proud of in five years
or ten years
I think we're going to look back at this
time and maybe be deeply ashamed of a
lot of the choices that we made and so
what do we do with that where do we
start how do we change things there's a
lot of work to be done that is a very
big question but I want to talk about
just a couple things that I think can
start to shift thinking and open people
up to looking at their work differently
and then hopefully opening up lots and
lots of new ways of working and one of
them is really thinking about how could
I work hurt someone this is a quote from
Zoe Quinn she was kind of at the center
of gamergate targeted by trolls
incessantly for years and she said you
know if you're not asking yourself how
could this be used to hurt someone and
your design or engineering process you
failed somebody at Twitter could have
used that like ten years ago
also still today but if you're not
asking yourself how could this be used
to hurt someone you're probably gonna
hurt someone so we need be thinking so
much more about the assumptions that
we're making and everything that we
create like for example if we look at
just that little tiny product choice in
the scale earlier right just this like
one little thing would actually be
pretty easy to tweak this so that you're
not sending people emails about losing
for the toddler but if you look at this
particular feature you see actually a
whole bunch of assumptions if you try to
work backwards from it here are just a
few of them the users weight is extra
pounds right so it's saying like you
must have extra pounds we've decided for
you you have extra pounds the user is
trying to lose weight but that's a goal
of theirs even though they never told
you that was a goal of theirs there's
also an assumption that the user feels
bad about their weight because there's
all this messaging that's like up
it's gonna be okay and there's an
assumption that the user wants the
scales help to lose weight as opposed to
just wanting to like gain knowledge or
data from the scale all of those
assumptions get baked in and lead to the
scenario where you're sending people all
of these weight loss emails who did not
sign up for them and didn't want them
now when we look at these kinds of
problems one of the things that I hear
very often is that this is an edge case
because you know most people if they are
gaining weight week after week you know
that's a bad thing and most people you
know they do want to lose weight I mean
you know America isn't a epidemic of
obesity so for most people this is gonna
work most of the time so that's really
an edge case and we can't worry about
that and I think that that kind of
framing edge cases can be useful and
certain kinds of like conversations
about technology but very rarely is an
edge case useful when you're
fundamentally talking about people
because when you're talking about people
you're basically saying this doesn't
matter right you're saying you don't
matter you're too far outside the norm
for us to care about you a couple years
ago when I was working on a book called
design for real life my friend Eric
Meyer we reframed and we said okay this
isn't an edge case like an edge case is
not a useful term when we're starting to
talk about how we make things for other
humans we need to talk about them as
stress cases and the idea of the stress
case is not just to say like somebody in
a literal stressful scenario although
that's part of it it's to say well what
happens what happens to our design
decision or a technology choice what
happens to this feature if we put it
under stress we put it under the
pressure of somebody who's not
necessarily our ideal customer or isn't
necessarily having a normal use case
what happens if that person's use case
is a little bit
and of what we typically think of when
we're designing this product does it
still work or not are we failing them
and what we found is that oftentimes it
was actually really easy if you started
thinking about stress cases it was very
easy to recognize little things that
could be big problems for people and to
make tweaks that would actually make it
work better for everybody the idea being
that if you can make something work for
people who have maybe a little bit of a
special circumstance then you can
oftentimes make it work better for
everybody who has the normal use case as
well so recently a friend of mine shared
this this diagram that fiord started
using where they built off of the stress
case idea and they started saying that
there's like a quadrant that they want
to think about so basically their take
is look if you go into a project and
you're only thinking about use cases
which is typical you're only going to be
thinking about the situations where
people are using the product and the way
you want and they are they're
intentionally using the product
correctly and it's one quadrant of how a
product gets used it's like you look you
cannot actually plan for every potential
case but if you don't think about some
of the cases and the other quadrants
you're going to miss huge things so the
way that this is designed is to look at
both so stress cases which is where
somebody is using the product correctly
but it's unintentionally failing them
right but also to look at things like
abuse and misuse cases so a misuse case
is when it's unintentional but they're
using the product incorrectly and then
an abuse case is when they're
intentionally using the product
incorrectly they're using it to hurt
someone or they're using it to you know
steal data right like those those abuse
cases oftentimes the only negative
scenarios that I've seen companies
actually go after our abuse cases if
anything and the entire other side of
the quadrant is ignored I think starting
to think about what are the use cases
what are the situations that we haven't
thought enough about and how can we make
sure that we are vetting some of our
decisions through more lenses I think
about this quote from Alex Stamos a lot
he left Facebook last year as the chief
security officer and when he left he
wrote this memo or he said you know the
problems that Facebook's facing right
now they're due to tens of
thousands of small decisions tens of
thousands of small decisions made over
the last decade and I think about those
little decisions because I think about
all of the little like weight Shanee
emails and all the little copy about
neo-nazis and I think you know it's not
like fixing that stuff or being aware of
that stuff is gonna solve major massive
ethical issues embedded in the business
models of technology but I do think that
every one of those small decisions and
every time we write them off and every
time we're kind of just doing our job
all of that stuff does add up and it
changes our perspective and it makes us
put up with things that we otherwise
wouldn't put up with because we've
become so numb to them and so I think we
have a responsibility whatever you end
up doing in technology I know many of
you are students wherever you end up
whether you're in academia or an
industry we have to think about the
unintended consequences of every single
thing we create from the very beginning
no matter what and the other thing that
I think we have to change that I think
is deeply deeply embedded in the culture
here is that we tend to worship speed
Silicon Valley is like really worshipped
speed for oh gosh at least a decade
we're faster is always better right and
even though you can say like Facebook no
longer has the motto of move fast break
things they still have the culture deep
within that company and deep within this
industry of moving fast and breaking
things and so when you worship speed
there's so much that you lose out on
there's so much that you miss because
you think that speed is success
Erica Hall has this post on thinking in
triplicate it's on medium it's really
great I recommend reading it's a good
long read she says you know things like
lean methodology and Minimum Viable
Product they're supposed to reduce waste
and increase the timely flow of useful
feedback get to market faster those are
seen as like de-facto goods inherent
goods right in practice though they're
used as a cover for rushing to a less
thoughtful solution without considering
the context of the long term
implications I'm not saying that we
shouldn't think about lean or agile
processes I'm not saying that we
shouldn't sometimes think about what a
Minimum Viable Product is but if we are
only hurtling forward toward that as
quickly as we can without thinking what
the context or the long term
implications are we are going to
continue hurting people and if you do go
out
to a tech company or frankly any company
that has embedded technology deep within
its practice which is like every company
now we have to be thinking about
inclusion what to be thinking about
ethics we have to be thinking about
worst-case scenarios at every part of
our process it's not like an additional
piece of the process I've actually
worked with some companies where they've
said well we really want to do this but
we're trying to figure out like how do
we add this new phase on to our work and
I'm kind of like well that's a problem
in and of itself this is not a new phase
you add on to your work this is a shift
in how you work so when you're thinking
about your roadmap when you're thinking
about your use cases when you are
thinking about you know critiques right
like I talked to an organization where
they hold like a weekly design critique
session it's an open session anybody in
the entire design organization can come
to it and they critique work-in-progress
and like okay that is a perfect
opportunity to raise flags do people
know what Flags to be raising do they
have the vocabulary to talk about it are
they empowered to talk about it do they
feel like they'll be listened to if they
bring something up this is not a new
phase this is just something you need to
build in to that very very great moment
for it look it perfectly designed for it
but nobody knows how to do it or isn't
sure they're gonna be supported if they
do it and then I also think we need to
be valuing a lot more perspectives and
backgrounds and skillsets and technology
now I am NOT coming from a computer
science background or an engineering
background I went to journalism school
and sometimes I've had people deeply
questioned whether I deserve to be
having this conversation I've had people
question whether I deserve to have any
opinion on algorithms and the thing is I
don't need to be a computer scientist to
be able to have an opinion on how
technology functions and the impact that
it has on communities and in fact I
think what we need are a lot of people
from a lot of different backgrounds
certainly not just my background either
for example one of the things I was very
very disappointed by in the whole Google
memo incident there was a lot that I was
personally disappointed by in that
incident but one of the things that
really got me was this recommendation
that James Day Moore had for Google so
he said now one of the things Google
needed to do
to solve it so-called problem of like in
thinking that it could have more gender
balance in the company was that he said
we should D emphasize empathy being
emotionally unengaged helps us better
reason about the facts I think this is
one of the biggest lies that we tell
ourselves in a field like stem because I
don't actually think that being rational
about the facts will solve any of the
problems that we are facing I think we
are facing fundamental huge human issues
that require us to let go of some sense
of rationality and the sense of
neutrality because what we're doing is
never been neutral and we need to
actually think about this in probably
like the most human terms we can and in
fact the most emotional terms we have
can because technology is entangled with
people's most intimate lives like we are
building technology that impacts every
single bit of people's lives and we are
entangling technology with our most
crucial systems of society right like
who goes to jail how voting systems work
we are embedding technology into all of
these places where it's incredibly
crucial that we understand we understand
the context that we're working within
that context as people and so to do that
we have to be much more emotionally
engaged not less emotionally engaged and
that is something that makes a lot of
people coming out of computer science
like deeply skeptical because there's so
much emphasis on like reason rationality
we're going to allow to logic our way
through everything and the fact is we're
facing problems you can't logic your way
out of because when you do you what you
don't have you don't have any clarity
about like whose job is it going to be
to consider the psychological and
emotional safety of our users that's a
really really hard thing to work on if
you're obsessed with reasoning about the
facts who gets to decide what fairness
is if anybody has a universally accepted
and mathematically quantifiable
definition of fairness please see me
after this class it is very hard fair is
a very hard question to answer because
fair has to do with culture fair has to
do with perspective fair has to do with
so many factors so we need people who
can like
deal with deciding what we mean when we
say fair and I don't think any one
person needs to be responsible for
deciding what fairness means and I
Stephan Utley don't think you should
have one random computer scientists who
happen to be the person who coded that
part of the algorithm deciding what
fairness means for everybody else who's
gonna help us with historical context
like if you're gonna build a product
that impacts people's financial lives
like decides whether or not they are
eligible for a loan and you're using
location data like zip code address
where they live
somewhere in that algorithm do you have
anybody who understands the history of
redlining and the fact that we
systematically denied loans to huge
numbers of black Americans for decades
and if you don't if all you have are
technologists in the room and nobody's
responsible for understanding that
history what are you gonna miss and how
might you be recreating those same
systems in the future and for all those
unintended consequences whose job is
that what I have seen so far is that is
nobody's job and there's nobody who
loses their job if you fail so what I
want to leave you with is an idea that
as all of you go out into whatever your
careers shape up as whatever you want to
do next I think we need to understand
that part of our job has to be rocking
some boats like we can't afford to just
say we're just gonna let it slide
because the company keeps making money
we're just gonna let it slide because
the research is interesting we can't
look around and kind of say like things
are okay even in a place like Stanford
where I know that there is a lot of very
interesting research happening there's
also a lot of excitement about
technology there is a lot of money
there's a lot of high profile work
happening in this valley we can't walk
around and just accept that what's
happening today actually works we can't
necessarily assume that the things that
we're building are going to be harmless
and we can't assume that this is going
to last forever the way it stands and so
I don't leave you with a quote it's
quote from Audrey Lorde in 1982 she was
giving a talk where she had talked about
wasn't changed during her time in the
civil rights movement from the 60s to
the 80s and she talked about a lot of
things that had changed a lot of things
that hadn't changed and she said you
know the thing is revolution is not a
one-time event
or something that happens around us
rather than inside of us change is the
immediate responsibility of each of us
wherever and however we are standing I
think about this a lot because I get
overwhelmed by the size and the scope of
the problems that that I'm talking about
in tech and I get overwhelmed by the
amount of power the companies have and
the fact that like I'm just this one
random person who has just enough power
to get in front of this class but
definitely not enough power to change
everything at a place like Facebook or
Google but I think it's so important
remember change the responsibility of me
and that the responsibility of every
single one of you so what are the
principles that you'll use to guide your
choices what matters to you what do you
actually believe in you may not believe
the same things as me you may disagree
with some of what I've said but if you
haven't thought about the principles
that actually should underlie your
decisions then you might wind up making
some choices down the line that you
deeply regret are you willing to say no
are you willing to say no to a company
that'll pay you a lot of money to do
work that you think is fundamentally
screwed up if you're not willing to say
no how much do you actually value it and
how much are you willing to risk for
those values are you willing to risk
parts of your reputation you're willing
to risk opportunities those are really
hard and personal choices to make but I
encourage all of you to think deeply
about what those might look like for you
thank you
[Applause]
you